yeah welcome a new Blitzer game playing
um a guy from Portugal here we de marzo
ternational marcin you got a Spanish
okay let's play the chi minh i played
and played this for a while and help
them he's not an expert I know a bit
about this line but not it's not great
my knowledge is limited so um d three
years on a good response quite solid mm
going to d3 yeah I experimented with
this check a while back leading to two
interesting play the idea is to first
provoke it move that white maybe doesn't
want to play like yeah c3 is sort of a
move do not quite sure a few of you if
it's useful and then I drop back to see
to see five because quite often white
likes to play Knight c3 35 however
Knight c3 in this position is not good
okay here i actually have the very
direct possibility to just grab it I
know it looks a bit weird but please do
to a very very solid structure for black
I have some experience with this and in
over the board blitz games at least and
it didn't work out so badly yeah I can
cover now c6 and he can play Knight to
g5 but I have got Queenie seven so it's
not not a big problem and also in this
configuration with b5 and and ce4 after
a six years forced to to give up his
bishop
so this is not a big deal the whole
structure is very fine for black I've
got an extra central pawn and note that
the missing knight on c3 which has been
taken by the bishop um yeah really
something that white would like to have
back Knight c3 d5 would be great in this
in this structure so one here wiedeman
doesn't have anything so it's just about
equal
yeah might have five this is some is a
good idea how to continue now mmm
interesting is also hanging you so I can
I can consider moves like Knight to g4
but then night at 5am is real a real
annoyance don't want that the question
is why would a 6 a-6 night f5 I can go
to f7 that's not a big problem ok a 6 if
he takes takes Knight f5 I still have
Queen f7 and now I'm taking you forward
to time zone after night f5 Queen f7 he
doesn't have a great move he needs to
yeah if he exchanges Queens place f3
then it's just it's just nothing for
wide aha yeah leaves the night somewhat
stranded here can I tear make you any
use of that what about Knight takes e4
Knight takes e4 Fe Queen takes is rather
simple 26 i can drop back ok takes e4
night f5 i take on d 297 94 96 at the
end I'm winning ok so just 94 right I
hope I'm not overlooking something
something very simple here it looks like
it just win support for black
don't really see what White's big ideas
yeah it just seems to win upon maybe the
whoop no I was just thinking maybe we
should be one yeah i'll just take here
yeah but it should should be fine rib
takes um I just move the Queen to f7 or
to f6 f7 maybe deserve the simplest okay
so this is interesting but what's the
problem he wants take on g7 hmm Bishop
Bishop to d7 maybe we should be 797 king
of eight and resigned some the queen is
hanging and it's got no move yeah this
should be okay just pinning the noid
97 king of eight then everything's
hanging the night the Queen and I'm a
piece up to begin with this of course
also possible so just King to g7
covering the sea porn for the for the
fog so let's return this night done a
great job and I'm born up to central
pawns
yeah just drew cafe next move and he is
basically two parts down even because of
them because of this doubled pawns so
what now he's maybe intending some
tricks he on the central files but this
this just gets the Jeep horn also don't
think he's got any any trick here coming
to have six next move and I'm even head
on the clock bye-bye some sub big margin
yeah the same this opening idea with
oops this was a bit too much this idea
and the Schliemann is quite interesting
as c3 I think it's a better this is a
very simple solution but it leads to
quite decent play for for black so just
just like that you when you have no no
big problems structures very healthy and
white white really it doesn't have much
play c3 is just just better here also
badass Knight c3 I can exchange as well
yeah thanks for watching interesting
game